en estos momentos chile y Bolivia
cuentan con gobiernos de izquierda puede
que esta situación favorezca de alguna
manera una agenda de negociación por
ejemplo sobre el acceso al mar
Buenas noches
no dudo mucho que esto contribuya las
afinidades ideológicas
generalmente han contribuido a los
acercamientos pero los intereses
nacionales están por encima sobre todo
desde el lado de chile así que lo veo
muy difícil y lo que se ha planteado hoy
día ha sido prácticamente una
proposición de parte de Bolivia pero que
no ha sido en ningún caso negociada con
chile ni todavía pronunciada o aceptada
de parte de chile entonces
aún cuando existen estas afinidades
ideológicas de izquierda es muy difícil
que esto trascienda en una mejora de las
relaciones ni mucho menos en resolver el
tema más candente y difícil que tenemos
entre Bolivia y chile que es el tema del
mar
Bueno y qué tan factible ya usted lo
estaba mencionando Pero qué tan factible
es llegar a acuerdos Si vemos que por
ejemplo ya parlamentarios chilenos
criticaron este plan de siete puntos de
Arce
es que por eso digo que es muy difícil
porque no hay un ambiente en chile para
aceptar lo que Bolivia ha planteado y es
un mensaje un discurso dirigido al
pueblo boliviano claramente y no así un
mensaje para iniciar una negociación
porque claramente ya se sabe de hecho
que chile va a rechazar tocar el tema
del mar en específico y eso imposibilita
cualquier acercamiento que se pueda
tener y mucho más difícil aún para el
restablecimiento de relaciones
diplomáticas que es algo de lo que
siempre se habla en estos casos no hay
ambiente en Bolivia para eso y creo que
tampoco lo habría en Chile Bueno y qué
otros temas generan discrepancias entre
Bolivia y chile y serían clave en una
eventual negociación
bueno son muchos temas de hecho el tema
del silala que es un recurso hídrico que
ha estado en la Corte Internacional de
Justicia es un tema que no se ha
resuelto aún a pesar de haber atravesado
el proceso también hay otros recursos
hídricos como el río lauca y el río
caquena que han sido desviados hacia
chile y sobre los cuales no hay tampoco
solución y además de eso está el tema
del cumplimiento del tratado de 1904 que
hoy lo ha referido también el presidente
Arce en cuanto a la aplicación del libre
tránsito que chile le debería otorgar a
Bolivia que no se cumple en los puertos
el ferrocarril arica la paz que también
no funciona hace más de 20 años el
minado de la frontera y muchos otros
asuntos en que tienen que ver con el
narcotráfico el contrabando incluso
ahora la migración que también es un
tema que le preocupa mucho a Chile que
son los temas que están sobre la mesa
pero que todavía no han podido ser
resueltos porque no hay un canal de
diálogo y no hay una buena relación
entre los dos países